you know what this is already getting
disrespectful no put that chin just
start rolling because I've had it this
is madam just roll yeah I'm mad I listen
in here yeah you can't you have to put
the mic on your stupid mouth
yeah just the way my Wang is gonna be a
man
yeah it's Nick the dick everybody and so
the microphones like balls you know they
can't carry when you do that all right
they all right there you go you're
wearing well what where were you were
you at a are you where you had a bouncy
house cuz look at how you're dressed
yeah the SATs or what's going on there
bro oh no I moved into a bouncy house
yeah Brian's right it's just really it's
really cheap okay and you wake up just
immediately you can stand up and then
point is right you start your day yeah
yeah yeah it's amazing see you're okay
so it keeps you effervescent yeah
completely effervescent yeah you guys
were late by the way I like people to
know that guys are not on time I was 10
minutes early so Bret Brennan goes like
this he goes that's so unprofessional
he's there already we're late I go
there's nothing professional about Nick
by the way it's not nice you need to
take we're not like formal Ryan but
you're you'll respect Owen I don't want
a tuxedo like you do outside of work
that's the thing about Brian's too
formal or he's just constantly walking
around in a tuxedo what she was what I
was she did he calls it a suck me oh
that's his thing because he has no it's
crotchless suck me Nick um one time when
he was really young Nick was funny by
the way you're killing it at 23 years
old yeah that's how long I've known him
you can say 19 yeah I know 19 I've known
you almost 20 years
yeah holy that's how long I've known I
met Brian in 1998 in New York yep hot
summer night dark bar yeah leather
leather swings I slapped him around i7o
I turned him Pinker than you already is
with the with both my hand Holmes yeah
and then we had we had some times now he
was always funny and then one time I was
gonna bring him up onstage and he goes
up
it was a shitty krasin this was in New
York I think we're at the comic strip
probably cuz I go what do you want to
sega's he said I play a gay guy in
Cameron Crowe's movie which was like he
was screaming and stuff David Bowie and
I introduced him as a gay god I thought
he said a gay God so I go he played a
gay God in this movie he's like a wide
and the hall it was like huh and then my
uncle I have my dad's brother I have
never heard anybody laughed this hard
cuz NIC NIC what the crowd was so [ __ ]
and Nick was always funny at 19 he was
already killing people right so he's
getting up there and I would always say
I'd always be like you gotta watch this
kid cuz he's 21 or whatever and he's
gonna be he's gonna be famous because
he's really funny so my uncle I say you
gotta watch this - so he's doing jokes
the crowd could give a [ __ ] about him
and he starts doing this this was your
punchline every time you were like ah
God ate someone's Turkey I'm just so
tired you guys ever eat a lot of Turkey
and just feel tired and he'd do another
joke that wasn't working damn Turkey
my uncle was I know me and my uncle were
a [ __ ] night he's just kept blaming
the jokes not on the ground but on the
turkey you ate did you aid he was i I
hate it but I ate like a pound of it
anybody ever you know pound of Turkey
and trying to call they weren't feeling
it
no because I literally did eat like a
ton of Turkey and I just learned that it
like makes you sleepy yeah so I just
kept blaming me tanking on the turkeys
every punch I was like Turkey oh so much
guys like do you even understand like I
was going through like some battle like
you would look down at my kid play with
school great on the story about Turkey
my uncle was [ __ ] crying
oh my god who you started in New York I
started Minnesota and then I moved to
New York our comedy scene in Minnesota
the comedy scene Minnesota's amazing the
good a lot of comics like ask for advice
I'd like to stay here for a while cuz
New York was rough like when I moved to
New York I was like this Minnesota comic
and I was like 19 when I start
I was like hey don't worry I like to the
crowd and they be like like they just
they don't know anything this eating
mayonnaise pig to their all isn't it the
land of the giants Minnesota like yeah
shake hands they all everybody has giant
big boys they're big they all look like
broccoli
Norwegians yeah the other big
Scandinavian take huge shits did you
hang out in a [ __ ] pit yeah now I it's
um there's a lot of bathrooms yeah yeah
but uh no I mean then I moved to New
York and it was like that was like when
I really started tanking I mean I would
usually have good sets but like I would
bomb really bad because I would be like
hey how are you and they're like what
the [ __ ] this guy sounds like yeah yeah
I know just I got booed off stage
oh dude Boston Comedy Club it was in New
York was called Boston Comedy Club I
remember it and I would do like Gina
savages that was a tough that room I had
terrible sets it was terrible and you
were a killer to are used to ripped it
why was it so bad I I don't know I was
just green if you were green like I was
young it's not a place to feel try
things right because you know when
you're young and you're doing stand-up
you're first of all you get in the cab
you go down I went to the Boston Comedy
Club I get up and I was supposed to
showcase for for Kent rush had me
showcasing for ya old are you at this
I'm ready
yeah I'm 78 out of probably twenty six
twenty seven and I and I'm getting up
there and I had this bid on penguins and
Turtles and I remember that dude and you
know you get nervous and I try to go by
wrote on it
I open with my name and they were just
like New York drunk New York dudes and
gals who are just tourists since older
and they're like get the [ __ ]
dead just dead sets yeah gonna cat gone
oh I was really bad well you and me were
both really physical comics so and the
stage is really small
yeah and so it's like you couldn't
really like tear into it so like they
want and Blake
I wasn't edgy at all my guy there no
edge like we were both like I wasn't we
were just yeah a couple guys did you
know we were Twinkie we were Twinkies
with the lipstick yeah you were always
really nice to everybody and whereas
most comics are like the aren't they
most people are bristly in Nick and I
would always be socially or calmly look
I still return every
single phone call an email that I ever
get like I'm never I've never become
that guy who I just it's my personality
I don't want to be and I think you've
always been the same way but but like I
would find like you go to like the rebar
remember with like we do those cool
rooms that you'd get up to it with
sometimes and then it'd be like the cool
kids like Marin and like Sarah silver
the lounge and and yeah and and upright
citizen okay they're all great but but
they were they were the cool kids they
were in LA already and we were anyway
for the window to come then when did you
come to LA I was in New York for a
couple years and murders row back then
to just kill everyone's killers out
there now cuz it would be like back then
it was it was like Amy Poehler
it'd be like we're in LA or New York New
York yeah I mean people this is when uh
gosh there were a lot of I mean yeah but
we see up there Gaffigan was starting
out and I was coming up then Gaffigan
see Kara yes Jonathan I just shoot a
Freelander I mean there was a ton of
great people Amy Poehler were she's over
everybody but everybody was young yeah
nobody was killed like you know no one
knew was Sarah had Sarah so man I
remember had gone to LA and then I
remember she was in these cool track
pants and something said and that's
Sarah so much she just got back from LA
and I was like la look he's he's okay
yeah yeah I don't know yeah I mean I was
I Love New York but I was psyched to
move to LA cuz it was just I don't know
it was so it was just too it's too
aggressive for me you know I like people
when you show up and you're new
everyone's like who's this [ __ ] guy
yeah so I was like hi a shock to you did
you find it shocking and almost too good
to be true when you started doing well
and and you became a comic of the Jews
because from you is pretty validating
like when you when you got into the
rhythm of it you kind of cut your teeth
and you ate [ __ ] literally you know what
I mean like on the ground he's into scat
and the thing is like you know the
mistake I made when I look back is that
when I moved to New York from Minnesota
I always wore a bonnet and I would walk
around and I meant that yeah
that hasn't ordered me off on the wrong
foot yeah once I took that off yeah they
started to kind of accept me but it was
get got in the way cuz it was so
innocent yeah it was we rolled out in a
huge baby carriage that was that was
super yeah with my little butter churner
now I just go and they would take me
around and they were like I think he got
a ditch so now he's a comic in a bonnet
but in LA they were friendlier to you
cuz it's still kind of the same people
just in LA though right at least
different la is different man that's
diff no people were cool yeah yeah I was
it wasn't that bad much space in that
way it sounds weird but like there's
something about LA where you you did
have more space New York where's me I
like New York I like doing shows in New
York where's Mia yeah and we'll change
in the rain chemistry man and New York's
like like all about stand-up so it's
like yeah like prime stage time was like
a battle to get so people are really
territorial like LA was more actors and
you know people like that was more of
the focal point I mean the stand-up is
always great there but people weren't
like fighting for stage time it was kind
of like my my saving grace was Lucien
holes yeah put me up first at the comic
strip at 8:46 her 826 everyday where
that that was my thing and I and I was
and and I was like I always open it's
hard and he goes well you're very
talented Brian you have a lot of energy
and you're good at getting kick it out
going yeah yes [ __ ] dude you were a
firework I was a real firework good
other words that get up and flip out
because I was so afraid that people
wouldn't laugh that's that yeah I mean I
let me pull not just a bunny out of a
hat
but let me expose my visions I'll do
whatever I have to I'll open a vein look
I'm bleeding
he still has more energy than what I
know yeah before I had an ability to
control and I was I think I don't know
they got along back then in fact we like
your energy so much yeah but I mean I'm
such a great guy you're right no I'm an
amazing guy say it you're about a
b-minus Nick what was the last part my
fear was like you were such a fiery that
you would light your dick like a wick I
don't remember that I was spreading
rumors well that was your peyote phase
you got really in the pan I
hey bring a shaman onstage well that's
because I'm half Native American Native
American that can't be true
speaking if I were you at that barbecue
at galvanic Isis in Venice when I
brought all those illegal fireworks I
know I went to a lot of his dammit I
went to a lot of those barbecues where
he'd have volleyball and everybody was
so unathletic
that I was so and I was the LeBron James
I was the broad brother dude we play
volleyball and everybody was tiny and
they were they'd never seen a ball
they'd never seen a ball and I would get
up and I just be like I'd be spicier
Fiona Apple when I was dating Fiona
Apple yeah she was like she goes I saw
you with all your hand stuff I was like
what she goes just the way you can
manipulate the ball obviously you know
you're so much more athletic and I know
you were showing off for me or something
I go no I know you're showing off I was
showing up for you joking around but I
was LeBron James that was a better Ally
but you're playing against like fat pail
improvise that's right yeah could never
done extras and stuff that would never
die I would I'd walk on like a bully
yeah it was it was not at all didn't do
you insanely high father what do you
mean yeah
what do you do like what's your morning
routine basketball my morning routine
involves a lot of backflips and then a
lot of stretching yeah and then I
immediately grab a basketball and just
are able about ten miles a day on the
freeway that seems a lot of traffic what
yep I just cross over cars I've never
heard that but that's amazing it's
pretty intense man boys doesn't your boy
Sandlin plays basketball non-stop right
he plays non-stop to the point where
it's like do you like I like he'll be
like we got like five minutes in between
setups let's just like play one-on-one
real quick and it's like there's like
scenes in movies all see me and I'm just
profusely sweating he broke my hand
playing basketball night to go and film
a scene and then we click and I might my
hand was shattered he shattered my
finger and like part of blocking the
shot or subject you know I took a ball
directly on my fingertip and it's split
like I didn't realize it at chatter but
it hurt
and then Adams likely to keep playing I
was like yeah right I'm like happy and
then and then I hit hit my fanned again
and it's like he just loves basketball
that's his favorite actor that's
Brenda's hero he loves Adams how really
I saw Matt yeah I watched all the stuff
his kid grow up he was my hair and then
I was at a movie and I thought I forget
what movie I was some kid movie and he
was there with his family by that right
can I have that first Mike like Adam and
then I went to the bathroom and he's
pissing next you know like god damn that
he said I'm like I don't be the weird
old man and like say some so I was
waiting he came up to me I was at the
Comedy Store two nights before I think
he was around then the canteen was like
you've got funny guy that kicks ass I
didn't know what to say is the first I
got nervous like me he's like what's up
man I'm like oh [ __ ] it's cool
did you take him out I double like him
right there and this kid's like no stop
my beat the [ __ ] out of luck
it's great it's great he's really good
invested but yeah yeah that's what I
thought yeah he's really good at
basketball I like deceivingly like you
wouldn't think he would be be he would
be good really yeah he's really good we
were supposed to go play I forget where
a New Yorker feet where was that but me
and Timmy Tebow which was go play
basketball of them here was that but he
I shut down a court like a straight-up
like professional basketball league wait
I closed it down and then Tim and I are
supposed to go play like five on five we
didn't go but if we got incident Tim and
I'm Tim Tebow and Brennan like muscle
then to a touch football game one time
they were just like in Denver these guys
a plan like can we join in [ __ ] like
Brendan and Tim Tebow Brendan Brendan
like was a d1 tight end and went to the
NFL could you know a crazy athlete and
and then Tim Tebow and they went out and
just threw at each other through passes
over guys like me built like me that's a
grit to meek the word it's me who's fun
that's what you I'm not meek at all I'm
bold
don't say meek yeah god I wish I could
be a fly on the wall when you're at that
party and just thought you're the man
strutting around like oh I walk around
like I'm like I'd like I'm a profession
and the Bron James I bully other when
they're a bunch of comedians I throw
punches one time one time Bryan writing
no I walked in the I walked in the green
we're doing it already do a show
together I walk in there's all these
commands around Brian and Brian it know
him behind him he's dead Sears seems
like and then one guy was like why and I
was like yeah and they've goose I took
one guy just [ __ ] drop them and
they're all in liar what and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on here but I
throw punches and I go huh I think goes
what is he saying I go nothing more
crazy because where was this Phoenix so
it's like local but I do live I teach
I'm like the guy goes this guy's just
been taking boxing now now I've been
boxing for three years okay when I say
boxing like I work with a professional
trainer right and I kind of spar with
people who look terrible and again there
it's like sparring with the dudes from a
lot of guys are from the volleyball guys
but I look awesome and and and I'm
sitting here teaching the guy footwork
and what not to do is I I go in a lot of
times I'll dip here and I say that if he
saw me it would be it'd be very makes me
sick I just want to be at some nausea I
want to be for me it makes me sick yeah
that's really totally makes me sick come
on I just like all these Phoenix comics
like Oh in awe Brian I'll up and yeah
what a jerk and I walked into [ __ ] on
the scene the [ __ ] going on here the
giant comes in who really fought you
should have ended Brian what is this
take it I guess you give me some tips
and rows you should have sent him to the
Angels I should hold your pants on
spanked you in front of everyone yes I
sent him to the Angels symptoms I send
you to the Angels why wait that's a
great thing Messiah then I wouldn't have
to do that before I killed someone I uh
times you know Chris Leben yes the
Crippler the Crippler yeah he was I
haven't touched him for a while but he
was a we used to hang out back in the
day and I remember one time I was doing
shows in Hawaii and I'm there yeah and
he came to the shows and I was there for
a week and I was like hey let's uh you
know let's drink a party and he's like
now I'm good so every day I like we were
drinking a party and he was like
now so find the last egg it's my last
day I know you're really not gonna like
rage if any ghosts all right you want me
to know into rage and I go yeah he just
yeah now he goes okay here we go oh boy
I got a prompt for a while yeah so he's
trying to stay so haribol so you start
doing sake bombs that I mean this is
like 12 years ago start doing sake bombs
and then all the second floodgates open
we're just hammered we go to Dave &
Buster's he chokes my friend out in the
middle of Dave & Buster's he just loses
it oh my god chokes him out my buddies
just frothing at the mouth on the ground
oh my we're all like oh my god and then
it just just literally escalated to the
point where like I beat him a pop a shot
he started throwing like leg kicks then
he got me like in a leg chokehold in the
cab cab driver pulled over it just it
was really old I I hung out with him in
upstate Washington and I was doing the
kick and he was there and he was doing
an appearance and his head like this
yeah it's got the widest head and a
triangular his body the triangle
shoulders he's and his fingers and hands
are so big he's horrifying he said and
he got he's so nice he's such a nice man
yeah but he was a little he was a little
out he got he started saying thing he
started to rage and you could see that
that that's one of his demons yeah Oh
peace I hope he's sober because he's a I
think he is yeah at the UFC gym good
he's a [ __ ] good guy so yeah so the
next day I was like - look at how come
he said he's got an awesome looking
fellow there look at him oh you don't
need to do what he did to me during that
a whole excursion he goes punch me in
the face oh my god no man I'm good and
he goes no punch me in the face hard as
you can I go I'm good dude I go that's
really weird
and he goes here's the deal if you don't
punch me in the face and five seconds
I'm gonna punch you in the face now it's
just like like right away oh my god god
that's so where where do you punch him
though in the cheek or something I would
not even know I punched some like meaty
area where like it just absorbed my hand
and then it's got such a wide face it's
like hi you go from one eye to the other
hello Craig gypsy - fighted with Bisping
in London and he just stood there and
put his hands down he was just like to
punch me oh no I never saw Oh Mike
did you just drop just dropped his arms
he had some rough dos yeah yeah I'm
gonna take a beating man yeah listen
Silva was having none of it but those
innocence fight was it really in the UFC
the game Chris leave and he lit him up
like Christmas tree oh that is very
horrible thing you know yeah Christmas
in our school is prime nobody's oh no
one knew that no it wasn't his probably
no one knew no one ever since very high
yeah moths came from pride we knew he's
a badass but he wasn't like the spider
right that's a solid photo that's great
if you're bit say god that wasn't me
that was me up for my first set in New
York look at sighs that oh my gosh hey
what are you doing now are you doing
movies I'm doing this show together yeah
I just filmed avatar 2 through 20 don't
know if that's the true is it trying to
be I can see you as many creatures yeah
that make for easy who are you playing
in it and playing Sims apps yeah not
came off the tongue real quick with Zim
zaps
he runs the tree of genitals yeah it's
like a glowing genital tree I think
that's true I'll watch the 18th I know
see him it'll make sense I will when it
comes out in 2020 yo
um no in all seriousness I start my tour
I just did two weeks on the road and
then I had a couple days off and so I
started a two-month tour Vegas Friday
and then San Francisco and then
Sacramento on the night take off all
over the place from there and I'm doing
a new special and yeah tickets are nick
swardson dotnet it's a very fun where is
this special I don't know yet I'm
leaning towards San Diego when are what
is the date though do you have a date I
don't have a date set but I don't have a
title yeah it's called many smells many
yeah I'm addicted to like having to just
the dumbest
we're like 20th
in Chicago tickets are on sale right now
by the way but um I need to I know I
just hijacked your thing but I need a
name for my special my wife's not
bipolar ape but my wife doesn't like it
much that doesn't work for me really
I don't think bipolar we were talking
about American but on our indie band
idiots don't call me idiot
Nick that's so rude on my bad soon as
you said my father my god this doesn't
you know that no it's not gonna be funny
especially called bipolar a-all right
yeah that's good
what about volleyballer yeah actually
you love volleyball so much Holly no
volley man I play volleyball
I love random [ __ ] man what about
volleying balls what if I called it cow
that's good there's something random
yeah that's not bad
American cow what if you call it
mediocre beard this is not a platform
for you to [ __ ] tear me apart I've
always been nice to you don't call it a
mediocre beard I'm sorry that back I
take it back Newman died in a while
humbie I let it go sometimes I just grow
my [ __ ] right yeah no it's solid dude
Thanks
yeah it looks good what no no I'm being
simple are you looking over there I'm
being totally sincere that's great
do you like youth kicks no I hate them
what lady footlocker did you go to don't
laugh it stop laughing at his [ __ ]
digs man no it's not
your shoes are sock shoes like aqua
sucks there and they were probably
expensive or they designer shoes who
makes them oh my god ballon ballon Vanna
and chaga
you make money you're able to spend a
lot of money on shoes well these I god
these I got in the Year 1928 so i
valeted my time machine when I got here
look like 2080 yeah and also using your
where are these crazy expensive designer
sneakers but then you wear these [ __ ]
things you got at Ross for less these
nike air shorts and then
he's their partner a t-shirt and a camo
thing you love my t-shirt
I do alright alright also my shorts have
zippers on them that's because like when
I get drunk which I've only been a
couple times am i right my stuff would
fall out of my pockets since I got I got
Zippy's so you have you have shorts for
your alcoholism yes okay but I don't
drink I actually don't drink as much to
people what do you spend your money on
seriously oh diamond football helmets
probably okay it's a good big one good
investment yeah I've seen that yeah um I
don't know I don't really like I live
pretty humbly I gave up my car I spend a
lot of money on food gave up your car
yeah I've got a car like to you over
everywhere yeah that's so weird to me I
have a neighborhood where I can walk you
know car wheel and stuff yeah yeah what
don't you like the freedom driving
yourself though I hate feeling like that
freedom or just insane anxiety if that's
what it was for me it was it's just like
it just added so much stress to my life
so I driving yeah I was always screaming
you suffer from anxiety cuz you don't
take elevators I know that yeah I'm
afraid of elevators I have like a little
bit of anxiety but it's not too bad I've
kind of like gotten over a lot of things
but yeah like sometimes yeah where's the
elevator thing come from really
traumatized as a kid I just never liked
them I remember what I was doing that I
was in doing shows in Boston and I got
stuck in an elevator I was with my buddy
Jay yeah and I'm not embellishing this
at all he knows I have a fear and I they
would not let me take the stairs so I
was like okay so I took the elevator and
also begin and it stops your worst
nightmare and my worst nightmare my
buddy Jay goes dude dude and I was like
and I took the doors I'm not joking and
I ripped them open I was like chased
like dude dude and I ripped him open I
just go shop job and he's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing like oh shut up but
he's like dude this is so dangerous and
he jumps down like halfway off the floor
and I just [ __ ] Waveland and just
dive out and we fall into the lobby and
doors closed
never again and unlike say my buddy J's
like oh my god my god is right yeah and
I don't like walk outside I think I
called my mom or something I was had a
completely very cool so so might my
friends Jimmy Burke's friend known her
forever she couldn't fly and she she
just couldn't fly her it was a major
problem she had gotten some job where
she needed to fly and it's a stewardess
yeah right yeah but she got this dream
job so she went through intensive
therapy and hitman two hypnotism to kind
of overcome this insane fear and also
like you know the chances of you know
there was the one plane crash of [ __ ]
every village for yourself was she was
the one in the plane that took off and
broke in half well and she died what's
the first photo I know her first plane
it's like that once more said so in her
first plane went up and at the plane
broke in half suppose it's so awful bad
I know that he survived is so it was all
[ __ ] gay no I thought you didn't say
and she died always think about her I
always think about her Khan huh I know
and then the right girl worried about it
is nothing for the plan to break [ __ ]
in half how long does this be it was
listen a Lego I don't know how does a
plane break in half it was made out of
Legos lady don't take a Lego plane
number one and she did yeah it's no it
was recently I got to get Jimmy to tell
me I've never even heard of them I feel
like you make the news if a plane fell
in half
well story though did Superman fly
through it
Southwest got sucked out of the plane
they dragged him back to him when she
died I was awful yeah yeah it was only
one person who died they saved her
grabbed her feet she's about to get
sucked out though I thought see I heard
that was only in the movies you not
bwilliant sucked out no that's real
looks like the movie Rovers at alien 4
where the alien gets sucked against the
wall and I just get yeah yeah yeah
is it flight 800 Brian yeah it's a 1990
something it's split in half mid area
send a bomb no matter constants they
think it's a bomb what I'm imagining has
to be yeah insanity damn Brian would you
make this a dark podcast man his was
happy he had this fear I had a really
long story where everybody's yeah I know
a girl died you need to learn right
along okay I'm gonna get all the
information that's why I'm doing it well
but what originators originally you're
scared of elevators why I've seen the
movie devil to it real yes I've seen the
movie devil it was horrifying even
movies like that I can't like deal with
it would you rather die this is a
serious question God what's wrong
would you rather die a plane crash or be
died by crocodile would we rather die in
a plane plane crash [ __ ] man hey really
crocodile crook with you know the reason
I'd rather do this question ever for me
it'd be like you just get drowned think
crabs no not true no I'm not true at all
bread he's gonna grab whatever let me
get a hold of twist it off and then tear
you down while you're screaming and then
you're still alive it's not good and
then he eats you out that's what they do
they live [ __ ] first yeah they sit
there grab you and they twist and they
pull you parts of your body up that's
what they do
yeah a plane it's like plane it's like
not do you know that my friend you
sounds like and then for game over my
friend you start dude like I want to be
yeah my friend what no you know what
there's a plane crash they have people
to go and inspect the crash site and
they do all the data collection and
stuff like that I don't know if I just
only the peanuts are left no they find
if your shoes are still there they find
that Brian's people go through their
shoes the other you'll through the chute
you've said that twice an odd cast I
like you is bright yeah it's so crazy I
mean have you ever been a part of an
emergency landing on a plan nope nope
have you yeah yeah that's pretty intense
what happened
I pulled an alarm open the window I
wanted to get some air screw
if you do that you see uh the TJ Miller
he was messing around called a bomb
threat oh yeah a bus or on a train they
arrested yeah but he was promoting a
special I'm just kidding
they don't [ __ ] around with that no no
no it's terrible no I was I was kind of
screwed I was flying into New Orleans
through a storm and they're like we have
to do an emergency landing remember he
was like [ __ ] does that mean
so they were like brace yourself we're
like for like yeah alright I'm going to
do OB get my armor [ __ ] shell out of
the jumping jacks in the aisle I was
gonna trip finish Corky Romano on my
laptop yeah I'm gonna brace myself but
people are freaking out and I was like
like the comic in me I just was like I I
just kept like trying not to laugh so I
was like well this is is that you know
people like oh and I was like oh I don't
know I guess you can make CNN I was
thinking about that if I die will be
make CNN I this is what I do when when
somebody's when somebody's next to me
watch this get scared that if there's a
real turbulence and this is how I act
ready again remember I talked about
fighting now watch how I am when you're
sitting next to me in a plant be a girl
and be afraid okay hey hey never worry
about this it's impossible that we would
crash where's your boyfriend because I'm
not because look at me look at me hey
come here first of all come breathe into
my mouth what why because it's helpful
with your nerves that's true yes it is
you this we're not gonna crash we're not
gonna crash now look at this that that's
real that's called an American boner now
let me finish
oh yeah that's where the strength lies
and how much strength enough to keep
this [ __ ] bird of afloat that's what
I want to hear yeah and we're gonna be
okay
all right all right yeah calling a lot
like Nick Swardson product do you know
you know who that is
so I'm not attracted to you even a
little bit
you're you're horrible come on you're
not gonna die so that's the good news
the bad news is you look like the comic
Nick horrible Swardson
but the good news is you're not gonna
die but that could also be bad news
because you have to walk around with
Nick [ __ ] sports ins terrible face
okay is that bad to me to me I and I
don't want to be too but he's revolted
oh my god and so you are revolting all
right well I want this plane to go down
down but it's already gone because I'm
looking at your Nick Swardson face oh
yeah I'm sorry to say this out loud and
I feel bad but do you feel are you
thinking about the plane crash I want to
go down fast there you go there you go
I'm gonna open this window really
hardcore therapy oh man thanks dying
thank you
I was solid Thank You Man and C&C howdy
to and seen so many blessings yeah too
many too many too many blessings oh oh
yeah and then I finished a movie last
summer called the Buddy games with me
and Josh Duhamel Olivia Mona Mona Josh
Mel are you really yeah what a real it's
called think like a dog and I'm doing it
in New Orleans in China stink like a dog
I just worked out my whole schedule this
morning she's in New Orleans Megan Fox
and Josh Duhamel I yes well that's all
right I've worked with him once on Las
Vegas but don't remember he's awesome
he's a great guy yeah Midwest kid North
Dakota yep big handsome son what was he
in last well he just did he's a total
chef sounds like he did he show know he
did it he's on a TV show
he's always work and he did transformers
eight or whatever
look at that cries of them yeah look at
me oh there you guys are
who's that guy is a stud he's a guy from
Supernatural and Janssen Echols hmm yeah
look at Josh would you guys feel mad he
did so much coke it's all in his beards
oh that's great yeah we were like dude
Diane was preying on
reading rumors where's that at Nick
that's in Vancouver Canada Vancouver and
I am Wow
yeah yeah a lot of size I got so high
Josh and George Hamilton that's crazy
Tanner I thought you were serious for a
second I was like that's not why you do
have Norwegian skin huh yeah fine of the
finest sausage no yeah it's good it's
hard our comedy great cast super fun
okay
as James heard a Kevin Dillon Olivia Oh
Kevin Dell is a nice guy Josh looks like
Hellboy Kevin countdown oh my god Kevin
Dillon I did a [ __ ] that we were on
Entourage together and we did this we
did this table reading under a tent and
it was super hot and and Kevin looked at
me and he didn't know what to say so was
one of us everyone was terribly awkward
conversations and he looks at me like
this and he's such a nice guy and he
goes I'm doing I go and then I go good
it's hot though huh and he goes it is
and then he goes then there's a pause
[ __ ]
I feel like Kelly's gotten a lot hotter
over the years the weather talk yeah I
know right
and then there was I so here we go again
yeah but we know you really should the
[ __ ] you at work
that's your small talk come on bro oh my
[ __ ] yes either let's try to get Josh to
get you off that movie yeah could you
tell some gamma texts I know yeah I'm
sorry laughing when do you start filming
um a couple days in May and then like a
week in June he goes [ __ ] on though
huh gotta go to China what's there what
are you doing over there
movie they shoot a lot of stuff in China
what what movies have you ever flown to
try to how long does it take can you see
how long that flight is 18 hours no no
it's not that mad I think 14 no
Australia's 14 to hours is it to two
sounds more like yeah I think that's
more accurate our teen hours
17 days god that's long I'm going by
boat I'm my boat
Oh that'll be cool 12 hours and 15
minutes I'm going to beige it sounds
like I'm joking
take a jetski dude what yeah a quick
it's like five months but it's so fun it
is whole time yeah just bring like a
PowerBar what's his name listen a
Rogen's podcast in the guide Peter of T
is a doctor swam from quiet alumni and
then back and then he goes but I had to
fly I would figure it out because you
can't swim at night because of all the
tiger sharks yeah yeah there's sharks
all that's crazy when you're doing and
then he does the Catalina thing the
Catalina channel where there are all
great lights everywhere they'd with the
fisherman that's where they fish for the
great whites and he goes um because yeah
you start at 12 at night are you out of
your [ __ ] stone no why did you do you
out of your seat don't you got crazy
that's from the 40s take oh my gosh gee
whiz if he sees that shot she was you
out of your stone why is he here
like why does he do it none of your
beeswax he just does it for the [ __ ] of
it I guess he just he's one of those
extreme you know guys I don't get it off
on that yeah I don't get into that
extreme [ __ ] I don't
ultra marathons I know you run up
swimming with George I run too many
marathons yeah I know that when I think
of you I think of marathon yeah um I do
it to blog it's so hard
stelios when I keep going like this yeah
yeah you got this well we won't talk
about you you don't far like that
Brendan you see when he got up oh yeah
um are we continuing okay cool now it's
just you and I hello darkness my old
friend mmm good would you like to be a
like would you rather be a great singer
songwriter or what you are which is a
great standup I'd rather just be me it's
annoying that ants are so annoying
well why don't you pick a
singer-songwriter that I would be why
don't you guys some example all right
bono what the [ __ ]
bah no I would like to I would like to
be bono that would be pretty what all
[ __ ] aside what artists kind of blow
you away or inspire you
mmm Bryan Callen yeah obviously because
I destroy duh um that's a good question
I don't who inspires me Tony Danza I
mean obviously I have his posters on my
wall who inspired I don't know I guess I
just solely any heroes you know really
inspires me in this is Charlie Chaplin
really inspired me I became addicted to
Charlie Chaplin for those of you don't
aren't familiar with Charlie Chaplin I
mean he's a legend icon but I go back
and watch his stuff cuz he was doing all
right I mean it's crazy what this guy
was doing I'm like 1920 yeah like short
films if anybody can find this short
film called a night in the show and it's
a short film he did early on probably
wolf maybe 1930 it's so hilariously
being loud was it too low it's fine it's
fine
who is that mom here we go through your
body and you would look down and then
die here we go
sit and you would go hmm what's the last
thing you would say to me oh you know
you'd say probably not to be a dick
you're always better I might say that I
might say that I would probably go um
see you later
that's how a man would do it Nick
Swardson done that I would probably
still try to promote my dates and then
see if they could like weekend at
Bernie's me put you up and then I would
you stand up move your mouth yeah
Charlie Chaplin we're time I tried
Tappan who I asked to who oh you caught
up with him didn't you don't be an agent
Brian sack of diarrhea
god you're really relative you're
relishing that funny would it be if Ryan
died you hate you befo would you rather
get bitten by a shark than as AIDS okay
I thought you're gonna say we should
rather get bitten by Charlie Chaplin or
a shark with AIDS yeah wow that was my
only option would you either want to get
bitten I don't wanna lose every time my
Charlie Chaplin though that's one of my
heroes why did he have it was that a
real mustache or is that a fake one
thing that was a fact there's a fake
mustache thank you why would he wear
Hitler's mustache because there's more
that was like the Hawaiian shirts on
where it's in right before that you know
[ __ ] history all right you're right
wait I just remember this story somebody
told me I was doing shows in Florida
I have florida shows coming up may 10 11
12 Orlando Tampa Fort Lauderdale a lot
of dates bro yeah so I heard this story
about a guy who's at a bar in Florida
and he was like out back and they had
like this kind of janky fence it was a
swamp
some guys shit-faced and walks over
smoking cigarette this time he watched
herds offense some guy goes hey man look
out man there's a gator out there I
think I get [ __ ] that Gator and he
jumped over the fence and that was the
last thing he said no luck that Gator
and then the thing this grabbed his leg
in his butt piece deuces he just went to
the Angels like really really high zoom
it this is this is a no-brainer
God it would be cool of angels I don't
swim like a Charlie Chaplin I know we
saw Bryan live dude that's so easy
yawning is that what he's doing there so
not cool to say that about me though you
heard that yeah I'm sorry
here huh oh [ __ ] work my leg work my
leg cuz you're into doing those are
great genes I don't know Levi's made
spray they're not there Levi's make
spray paint let's go famous oh my god oh
so much fun we should at I'm sure the
other three of us yeah three highlights
out alike will cook and he'll do he'll
get all you'll cook no pants just the
[ __ ] and you're gonna want you're
gonna wanna Bob roughed up if you know
what I mean quote-unquote everyday hubby
you have to quote unquote that I think I
know a roughed-up me yeah but I mean
depends what your definition of roughed
up is explain to a boy well you're gonna
get [ __ ] by that I mean we're gonna
put our correct if you know what I mean
are you getting what we can your quote
you mumbled on he said dong yep you can
also say whatever you want to say either
way we're gonna put our plural yeah you
don't sound confident about though
you're like yeah we're gonna put her
don't ya I don't like to be explicit I
don't like being vulgar oh oh yeah I
just made up for your [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
yeah
that's the name of your special [ __ ]
[ __ ] look at that that's your
special that's your album that's your
tramps down I'm getting that's your
grill oh yeah
sign up I'm not doing that make you a
grill right now yeah yeah smile he needs
weren't you Invisalign hold on oh I
forgot [ __ ] let me see you long
before you've only let me see your teeth
gross okay not having ding okay not
working oh hey least their sterling
clean you get those out of your pocket
Brian they're not working bro well you
gotta go metal Gary then bleeding we
have to go metal is my I have Nick
letting your on metal braces not this
[ __ ] yeah you need like steel like
yeah egg yes like jaws from
double-oh-seven yeah oh yeah 14 year old
high school oh yeah that guy's and acne
you need acne my skin is so good though
I have good skin oh yeah thank you hey
Nick I look 51 ok know you'd know you do
have good skin yeah yeah housewives is a
bummer how old are you Nick
41 god damn dude I've really known you
since you were 19
yeah literally a weird that's crazy that
is [ __ ] weird men you do have good
skin though yeah who's your
dermatologist will or
that's not I don't even think it's funny
so why are you laughing at your joke
you're laughing at your own joke no I
wasn't yeah you were you know I got a
lot here your beard Chuck ruff what made
you guys [ __ ] decide to talk about
Charlie I try to have a serious
conversation I go who are the people
that inspire Charlie go seriously
charlie kappa you got somebody from the
[ __ ] is ryan
create its character ever that's an
amazing character yeah look at Brian
Nick you do I'm what's called broad
acting would you ever want to do like
you know real acting um oh yeah when I
stop booking these jobs and alrighty
thank good lord man ok here Washington
how would do you do stats out here in LA
I don't see you at the store and I do
sometimes but like when I'm home I just
want to like chill out
so it's psyching you know I'll do some
sets but I don't like crush it like
certain guys like delete goes up like 10
times oh crap now well I watched yeah
sylia goes up literally every night he
just yeah every night yeah I talked to
his girl last night I go what didn't
Chris do today and she said he went guy
he got coffee he went to the bank and
then he went to coffee and then he went
to another coffee shop and then another
coffee shop and I go bro what are you
doing at that time what are you doing
and he goes I look at my phone and
looking at people
he's automates content though he gets
content Instagram Solaris video and set
us up he sent us a picture of all these
checks right really [ __ ] around with
each other the group text so we get off
the road send pictures of all that our
money just [ __ ] with each other and
he sends a picture all these checks big
checks and there's these fat tits behind
the check I go bro let me up those tits
who is that he goes that's my girl manly
I know don't send a picture your girl in
cities
I'm living my life I know I just heard
that you don't like your day consistent
you watch the bank then you went to
coffee I go to the banquet ah system you
figure out that you're gonna say money
don't move on D all right okay get
coffee what did I go to the bank then I
go do just hang out I'll give you a
little taste of my life soundtrack dude
[ __ ] D'Elia man that's pretty solid
yeah
I'm not a coffee guy you guys coffee guy
yep couldn't get any bigger he drinks
coffee line coming out in June yeah
really and he gets himself sick over
yeah I start doing all those drink here
stuff ya can exert like out of nowhere
like he'll talk to you any goes yeah and
this throws up that's you know I copy
guy at all no that's always fascinating
why not um I I used to I started
drinking it like heavily on myself when
I started like doing movies where like
Grandma's Boy was the first movie had
produced and honey produced grams boy
yeah the great Baroda produced it
co-wrote a producer co-starred and so it
was like a lot of work so I just started
chugging coffee I was like that's what
you do just you just looking sugar
coffee and I did like drank like 10 cups
and I'm just completely shattered my I
grabbed some way out of it
I got Grandma's Boy out of it but get
back I kind of learned my lesson that
I'm so extreme like when I do stuff like
I'm not like oh one drink I can't like -
I just go hard in the paint like give me
the rock hard
dunk it jail you know what I mean yeah
yeah who else did you like grandma's
born with um Allen covert who was the
lead of the movie in and then Stanley
would throw in some little gems Doris
Roberts you do with yeah I love Doris
she was great and he's so good they're
good glass yeah I love that movie that
was fun I got to go dude and bad with
Shirley Jones and we filmed the scene
where we were in bed together when I
said I should have worn a condom which
was Sandler's line he gave me
last minute we like Kiwanuka and then
her husband and her son were came to set
that day that's so that was not weird at
all
no I just sat there while they were like
ten feet just staring would you guys
film that do you buy I'm like some roof
top that says yeah
Dubai on some rooftop we filmed a lot
downtown Los Angeles how did you meet
Sandler did he seem to stand up JDate
I thought so yeah why Tommy even Jewish
so the week okay no we we met he saw my
first Comedy Central Presents and he was
in bed with his wife and they were just
channel surfing and they stumbled across
it and my first company something
presents never might be a CD about my
grandma so he would tell the bed it's so
[ __ ] stupid what's the whole thing it
makes me feel really strong she can't
lift anything
she's like mean this jug of milk and he
lifts it up and it's so done I was like
hanging out with all people you feel
like amazing so I did this whole thing
about being strong oh my gosh that's us
in Vegas we went for the Super Bowl
I am so violently hungover it's insane I
look like every cast member of The
Walking Dead you look look I look like a
thousand bees on my face yeah you look
rough there for sure yeah I'm not even
looking at the camera - everybody else
is like totally on point yeah I'm like
going down in flames mounted group right
there yeah some solid people who said a
lesbian cop in the left what's weird
snake you know that economy's doing
spades always been fun yeah yeah he's
super funny I remember one time he
called me up and you guys thought
because you want to see Bryan Adams and
Def Leppard I go the answer will always
be yes just so you know that I go what's
the deal you guys it's in San Bernardino
and I go how are we getting there and he
goes I got a helicopter well I go yeah
that's I guess all right yes do it
yeah so we go to Santa Monica Airport we
get a helicopter it's him and me and him
and this hot blonde he's with smoking
hot so we get in the helicopter take off
and then I realized there's no bathroom
in a helicopter I'm really smart I
barely graduated junior high school so
huh there's no bathroom helicopter out
to pee violently
so I'm sitting there and we have like
another like 40 minutes so I go I have
to pee like really bad like the
dangerous a bad
so David goes we'll just go out of the
window so there was this little slide
window and I slid it and I'm so dumb but
I thought you could just pee and it
would just go out no like it would just
go like a little stream huh and it just
hit it like a fan and just sprayed all
over his dates all over the check out
all over and they're both screaming and
he's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
huh that's like you said pee out of the
window because I was joking you can't
pee out of a [ __ ] helicopter I go
sorry magnum p.i and I'll [ __ ] live
this rogue lifestyle you [ __ ] little
elf [ __ ] twink you covered them in
store this year and sports in urine yeah
oh and shower girls shower you [ __ ]
yeah bring me it brings you down to
earth because you guys are you're high
above you're above traffic you think
you're better than me watch this enjoy
wearing my piss yeah just shoot me I
will with my piss that's your new show
God that made simple rules of pissing on
your date yeah yeah
no rules of engagement with my dick he's
Joe keep you like before the Internet if
he had a fetish you had to like kind of
like joke yet to figure out he couldn't
find a community without the Internet he
doesn't know he did just joke he'd be
like it's like you know you're getting
pissed on me neither just kidding
alright
yeah I gotta take a piss let's go ever
be on you just kidding okay yeah it was
like in 1970 years like let me add a
doubt you'd be like Victoria you look
beautiful tonight yes you're gonna get
the salmon that's great I'm gonna go use
the bathroom unless Roman did to piss
all over your tits and if she's like
what the [ __ ] you like her kidding that
was a joke why would anybody do that
it's disgusting and there they are
demons and then I would go what about
them I met this she was like yeah I'm
down then you'll be like in yeah but you
just had to like throw it out there piss
off
my family there are people into that
hello those people in doing up a lot of
people my entire family reunion to be
specific no a live-in fetish come from I
had it in college I there was a girl who
said to me go she was such a bad girl
and she goes I've always wanted a guy to
take a bad girl I know he said I've
always wanted I take a champagne bottle
shake it up and put it in me in spray
and I was like oh wish him I was young
and I was like oh okay and I say to my
buddy Joe I go she wants me to put a
champagne bucket at Beau and my buddy
goes do it [ __ ] do it why wouldn't
you do that I was like I'm not in I
don't wanna do that I'm not in the weird
that was never into the weird [ __ ] you
know I don't know
oh you gotta do that man all right not
hard fast it was a long time ago I was
19 when she asked me to do that and he
didn't do it
no I think that was a prime time that's
prime time to do stuff like that
I thought girl through where before they
wanted me to hit him like hit him home
oh yeah yeah yeah whoo you're kind of a
big brute today do they want that Fifty
Shades of Grey type of [ __ ] you might
you probably when I came acre there's a
difference between like oh I know but
they're not harder but no I'm gonna go
to jail yeah no I don't like that
there's not a turn-on yeah hitting here
is not like Jesus what do you want to
close my fist like I have no interest in
and loosen a tooth a what that [ __ ] what
we talk yeah like what do you just want
to just keep going nothing you can do it
she's like all right
shine out I would have I'd hit you and
the girl I was on the plane with who was
scared who I had your faith oh that's
cool no no one days here have you ever
had to call 9-1-1 have you ever had
somebody attack you cuz you have fans
stalkers I've had some weird stuff but
nothing like too bad I've been anybody
attacked me yeah yeah I think cuz I
surround myself with body garage options
I have giants a circle like Floyd
Mayweather
yeah I have Floyd been with me whether
you watch sports a lot right I'm like I
have a horrible sports problem where
it's like to the point where my agent
called me we were on this tour and he's
like there's some cities like we
probably can't go to you and I was like
why excited I just would get drunk and
just tweet like belligerent horrible
things oh really oh my god yeah yeah
it's like I get yeah I my twitter during
football season is so out of control
it's I mean what your team is obviously
the Vikings Minnesota spike Minnesota
sports are such a disaster like Vikings
are good the Vikings are gonna be at a
heartbreaker this is we have a
heartbreaker every year we've we've
eaten just hot
Timberwolves aren't terrible we have
game 5 tonight and we just got blown out
by like 25 points last game so and then
the wild got knocked out of the hockey
playoffs we got embarrassed when we
overall so it was really good it's not
like you're philadelphia five years ago
well yeah but we Vikings have no Super
Bowl rings I mean the Timberwolves have
no titles we barely squeak into the
playoffs wild have no nothin twins f2
world series 87 91 so I mean it's not
you're serious it's not great watch all
the sports
yeah Brian we can't just all sit around
and watch figure skating like you do you
know what I mean people like want to
watch sports some type sports yeah and I
know yeah drama yeah we can't just sit
there in your living room usually for
most our house if you did pro athlete in
one sport what would it be I always have
this debate would you rather be a star a
star quarterback a star centerfielder or
a star power forward all power forward
all day less injury watch guaranteed
money
so is baseball like guaranteed money and
no injuries and the thing is basketball
people see your face when you're
football player unless you're like oh no
Beckham jr. or Tom Brady you have a
helmet on so you're not that famous
alright code let me let me let me get
more specific would you rather be
I like the Brennan's thing about the
fame and most people would be thinking
about like the game the play
right oh we're gonna play well let me
ask a ball well let me ask you this let
me ask you this
finally what you won't know these names
but would you rather be Tom Brady and
Derek Jeter or LeBron James yeah did
miss Ryan's like what who are those
people it's not a good impression of oh
my god Jeff that's a [ __ ] I've never
done that
my beard is great that's what you do
that's a tough are you in though when
you feel like yeah save me a more
specific
probably LeBron though right not Brady I
had to do those are all pretty either
way honey lives
yeah win-win but the amount of training
like physical training that goes into
being a basketball player keep talking
that matter maybe even a football player
but baseball seems to be a little bit
more no baby no baby
baseball's read Swisher Derek Jeter cuz
yeah they make games they play there's
no a boom go grab another spring ball
yeah and then you're traveling on stuff
out of all those it's guaranteed money
yeah basketball and baseball so longer
career maybe basketball that hombres
been playing for and at six
that's the exception that's an anomaly
it's an anomaly yeah but I my Busey
amount of pain the head injury the
footballs [ __ ] you're always injured
your hands right I think I'd be
basketball for me it'd be the Brawn
that's more fun yeah
smaller things were for travel and style
yes less people on the team so you don't
have to deal yeah oh yeah I would say
and if you want to you want to you could
just kick the ball into the stands you
know what I mean yeah you kicked up just
kick it okay you believe nobody's ever
just done that just unload and just talk
to you would be last on my list
yeah so Hawk you be gnarly it's not that
doing wrong it's a big swarms not huge
in America right yeah I mean you know
Patrick Kane would be pretty fun to be
though he's he's pretty sweet honey
unless you're unless you're cross beam
you walked into the office right now
and a hockey player nila who gets laid
more football players baseball players
or basketball players I'll take off
beyond that answer
yeah hockey players crush it yeah
basketball is a close second though yeah
I would say basketballs
I think that's LA has more [ __ ] around
them than anyone okay oh geez I go to
basketball games oh yeah or two unless
you're trying to [ __ ] women we were
having a great time and then somebody
came up with the W word mm-hmm yeah
all right ray will pray for Brendan
we'll be right back with some Bibles and
it's really kind of attitude yeah let's
go Jim what do you got brother all right
let's check this one out
the first one is 13 truck drivers formed
hold on one second I got another one
boo I know well it's there so cops in
Michigan talk to Lewis they shut off the
freeway someone was gonna jump off a
bridge an overpass so cops closed the
freeway and then radio truck drivers and
flagged down truck drivers to go
underneath the bridge so the guy
couldn't jump off you could jump in
between them that's the thing that's all
saying too however how bad you want it
bro yeah couldn't he just go on the side
and off the side
why what that's not even that's not even
that far that's not a high bridge no I'm
telling you but it happened though this
happened to me I'm lower on the 110
Michigan i-696 I think Nick this having
me on the 110 they stopped all traffic
some news about to jump off and we're
sitting there for damage three hours and
the guy was just sitting there cops
trying to talk to mom in the front I can
see it and a grandma about 80 years old
just she's sick of waiting goes just
[ __ ] do it already good god damn girl
well I mean you know I stopped I asked
the cop I went that's not that high I
feel he's just gonna [ __ ] up his legs he
goes oh no they've definitely died huh
you went they Duffing father don't they
also try to jump in to get head fired
car on the town they jump headfirst yeah
oh no it's not like they jump and do a
cannonball
yeah they jump headfirst like a goddamn
Olympic why would you do i Casper if I
was gonna do that I would see how
whatever skill bridge you
do a big no this guide I would like go
up at least have that moment think they
say that's the worst part if you're too
high if too much time to think gosh and
I've done this hey douche yeah but I
mean it I don't want I don't know at
least at least you're flying least you
have a minute where you're like you feel
like this kind of a bad idea okay but I
am flying down squirrel
yeah that'd be kind of sweet you're
right world suit no parachute then
you're like what I want to keep flying
but no it's into the road cuz you're not
a flying squirrel right I don't know I
think I would make a meal out of it I
would do a big ugly jump off of a gentle
plane well you said I just said that no
I'm saying like Southwest though I'd say
like Southwest yeah bring people with
you
no I'm not going I'm just like closer to
after me see you that's that does not
make sense
we'll be right back with more Bibles
we'll be right back
you oughta make sense either I could I
could make it happen this doesn't make
any sense see the guy right there these
truckers all agreed to do that yeah they
were all on board with the poor guy at
least he knows the war thing is the guy
Arabic who you trying to film love baby
yeah they know people care that somebody
cares about him that's a big convert
always a huge deal yeah by the way that
guy ended up killing himself what didn't
I mean that's another comma I know you
guys know what a lot lizard is my uncle
and Grandpa were truck drivers Oh a lot
lizard let me educate you guys a lot
lizard they have to stop at night a lot
lizard is a gentleman or a young lady
who sucks off the drivers yeah yep yep
where's the application lot lizards
oh no app required to show up lot lizard
friends summary flattering my friend's
sister its muted [ __ ]
lizard makes me think of Brian skin when
I hear that so it's like a lot less I
feel like you could you just said I
definitely get a dick thing to say
although I had psoriasis so just don't
be weird your socks go bro AB sup how do
I know it's not bad at all
silent throw-up wait what is wrong I
knew it I knew a guy um doesn't matter
it means I just do I have that system
yep you will today I know we chose you
got it you got the California bear on
your shirt yeah Louis Vuitton logo
mm-hmm that's Las Vegas only good
choices here those are drunk tattoos
dude yo hello Ryan yep nothing drunk
about this tattoo my friend took me to
Lionel Richie let me see so I got hello
Ryan
nobody Ryan yeah that was from a cruise
ship those are the worst tattoos Nick
they're pretty great just have one says
Pogue pretty hilarious
bTW it's a rose and what is that
supposed aughh from yeah that's Swedish
means today forward this one I got in
the cruise ship with Chris Kirkpatrick
from NSYNC that says best trip ever part
two oh and that's half of a heart and
then he has the other half is that real
that's real no his wife is like what the
[ __ ] is happening right now
well I cruise Europe
she's like oh my god that's what's
happening which one is that from NSYNC
he's a do with the braids pull him up
Chris Kirkpatrick
he's the do - bangs neck behind web
stack so [ __ ] off Nick I know Nick is
crying [ __ ] that's why he doesn't what
is wrong back then that's your boy when
I wonder if this girl's Nick Swardson
and Chris Carr Patrick and see if that's
your boy yeah it's my [ __ ] homeboy
yeah there's a matching tattoos today
he's producing music and stuff he's
killing it age tends to a scroll up it's
gotta be there this picture of me and
kiss I will powerful brain then there's
Nick bread game strong there is that it
yeah yeah he'll be ribs Brian come on
Jake real beards but look at him how
kiss you kiss yeah real beards for men
like man yeah that was wife was like
what
seriously what's happening we boarded
the boat and this guy it's like I'll
give you a free tattoo I'm like yeah I'm
not getting a tattoo on a cruise ship
after 78 sea breezes later couldn't
think of a better idea
tattoos my naked is my little Co tuning
oh no sin tell story but I'm bored with
all right go ahead my friend has a
sister who's has a sex like things she's
just crazy you just said you were a dad
they were at a truck stop she went to
get some stuff and go to the bathroom
her sister looks at her and goes I'll be
right back
oh she's a llama and she was she was
they were stopped they're on their way
and there was this cowboy who was a
truck driver a real handsome cowboy
and she goes what are you doing and she
goes don't worry but I'll be right back
she went into his truck look they'll
[ __ ] him and then got out of the truck
and then said see it and got back in the
car she and her sister was like you have
to stop doing this you're [ __ ] great
Wow
so much she had no yes her sister who I
knew so that she was good love like that
sounds like a solid well I didn't
believe her then I told you I asked the
girl and she said oh yeah
that's what I do as a cowboy he was hot
and I just wanted to do it oh the cowboy
was like why I know I know what yeah my
way to Oakland suicide I started talking
to him I told him I think I had that
thought he looked like the Marlboro Man
or something or I like this moustache or
something and he was like oh and then I
just basically told him that I wanted to
[ __ ] him in this truck dude chicks will
crush Cowboys I swear to god I went on a
retreat when I was like in church camp
yeah we went to Wyoming we were like it
was like it's our senior year and there
was like you know the Cowboys that
worked on the ranch first ant mmm and we
were all trying to get laid and there we
just there were zero powers against
these Cowboys they were just wrecking
balls just [ __ ] vagina but just
racket going through all the girls on
the ground man
it was just a softball to compete there
on horses they smell like leather yeah
smell like wind and wind
yeah mooing prairie freedom what do you
what else yeah chin so actually oh look
at that
oh that's me getting my tattoo I thought
are you holding his hand no no yeah you
are
oh yeah oh yeah I'm getting a tattoo on
the other arm and I'm holding a sec yeah
and you're in your married
yeah little stop those gay rumor did you
make him cover his face when you cuz you
don't like looking at his his human face
no we do a whole roleplay where he plays
the Phantom of the Opera
okay it's a specific reference nobody
won
Tyrion Jim quick sports one oscar de
lewis is a triple G inconel are
happening in September and they say
canals gonna wail on him what he didn't
elegant sleazy my dad Grampa trying to
talk trash and guess what everyone he's
gonna wail on them that's gonna hype
ticket sales triple G's fighting May 5th
still you and some no-name we should
just destroy yeah and then can help
listen in box and when guys get busted
no one gives a [ __ ] I think yeah okay
anyways when they gonna fight spend them
for six months that really slap on the
wrist not really being a 12-round fight
like that the steroids matter yeah they
definitely do Brian
but Bill Stewart oh but of course why
the other stupid [ __ ] his fights
twelve rasa's more cardio isn't it more
of a I don't know like that's the
dumbest thing I've ever feel like
steroids wouldn't they hell no I would
ask everyone from the golden era of
boxing they were all doing steroids no
what is wrong with you thank you why did
you bring him I don't know my god I'm
sorry how did it security move on chip
hopefully that yeah [ __ ] yeah cow
Seward's okay so average Joe art
actually sent me this article something
about a golden state killer who's been
on the run forever for four decades
someone was actually finally arrested in
this case now
they on the left good lord
oh my god that looks identical to the
UFC every chance is not there yeah the
guy that looks like Uriah spelling me
imagine getting killed by the guy in the
left by the way oh hey if I could be
Kairos returning your paper
I'd rather get killed with a guy in the
middle who was the set of hero of a they
found him or what yeah so this is crazy
so look at his rap sheet thought he
would killed at least 12 people oh my
god rape 245 at least 45 women and 120
home burglaries 72 days and it was like
a cold case to configure who it was and
then of all people you know Patton
Oswalt yeah his wife he was writing a
book about this yeah Michelle yeah did
you know her yeah also she was writing a
book about it and then she was working
with authorities figure out who was and
then she named someone as a suspect that
suspect she named was the person that
was arrested holy that's amazing i'ma
show is brilliant rest in peace passed
away yeah and the best away honestly it
awful there is Joseph can imagine being
this terrible [ __ ] person who's commit
all these crimes but you you've gotten
away with it this long that 70 to make
him knock and you're like [ __ ] yeah that
would be insanity he ran to a Shinto how
the [ __ ] did they so how did he get
caught she just thought he was a suspect
and then they started looking into it I
guess they just found out all of the so
arrested overnight and two murder
charges by police in Sacramento it
started also who's staying on the case
that long you know what I mean because
it's like [ __ ] to do there was DNA so
much stuff families do family stamps
know the victim oh right how they still
exact a date they keep they keep
somebody to hire somebody but um hold on
how the [ __ ] did they catch him there
was DNA areas he covered his show very
well he'll said what he didn't account
for was DNA technology yeah yeah but who
opened it back up it's always been open
but Jane Carson Sandler wait what who
said she was raped by the killer 1936
used to insult Kelly she you
to want to punch him in the face yeah I
believe people like this are truly sick
like I believe that they have something
wrong with their brain oh you do bro
yeah I mean that's a perfectly healthy
butt but it for closure for people for
victims a lot of time times they find at
least some solace and the idea that this
is a sicko that wasn't personal that
he's a crazy person that that you know
that this is a disease almost it's like
instead of like I feel like that doesn't
help I think it does I've read enough
accounts where people are like the way I
do my gateway into forgiveness was the
idea that this guy couldn't help himself
that that's you know that he was obvious
so you're saying this guy was sick in
the head yeah that's catch tell me
that's from the 70s beam
oh that's Deadpool yeah I was gonna say
that's a Deadpool yeah I sent it so he
found him yeah he's right that's how I
met Bryan back in the East Village that
was a leather swing set that's what you
were working in recent years there was
renewed interest in the case this year a
book and series from HL and we're
release hoping to shed more light on the
case when secretary rapes were first
being reported all right and I might add
God wonder how they eventually caught
him they like they were just I find it
walking their dog killed a couple of
walking that dog maybe rethoric launched
him he just sent it to me and it just
happened maybe find a new so this is in
China and a pregnant woman tripped a
little four-year-old boy because all my
grand through that to this restaurant
like one of those little curtain things
hit her bowl and it you know drip some
of her food off her plate and she's a
pregnant woman too so I'll show you the
video right now and she's getting so
much hate right now let's see it here we
are so he's running through two grab
chopsticks for his dad on the next
building why is there 17 people talking
see that the plastic hits that girl
sitting by the door straight in the face
causing her to oh nice type move kid
kaká enjoy those noodles beot Oh
stretched out he comes running out boom
oh boy did he get hurt you did go to
hospital and it was there were some
articles that he had a concussion or
something but what did he land on a
carpet look like he was like fellas
crying but what is fine well yeah what
is she's here just so much crap so she
actually had to turn herself in to the
police because all these people watching
the video we're trying to track her down
and kill her
yeah and there's give you a bowler baby
out she's pregnant too would you crazy
baby I'll get the baby out of there get
the baby out of there I'll give them too
so now get that baby out of there but we
have known and the way to the payroll
naturally what Nick you're being
terrible that's also raised sisters cuz
they're Chinese what what is that it's
racist even you're applying that there
so he wanted if I needed I never said
anything about deep frying and this is
all on camera save the baby live forever
no my skin is black you know eight
babies dude yeah what a stupid [ __ ]
though am i right fellas
well that's an aggressive word but she
is a [ __ ] no she's a conte toilet [ __ ]
Kenneth said had been all right I think
she probably shouldn't so what happened
to the cops do anything besides that
person would [ __ ] say we're gonna
give her like I think ten days in jail
but since she's pregnant so they
couldn't do it and then the parents of
the kid also said like please Lera lawn
she's getting too much hate so thank you
for like last yeah I don't know what
they do in charge for people to be
horrified it's a little dramatic I mean
it's like I'm not like how you suck it's
a Kunti [ __ ] toilet [ __ ] [ __ ] bootcut
you know that's what it is that comes
off
yeast yes Kunti a lot but and but um
yeah I be hard to see are that a slapper
yeah she's suck I'll have to go back
there go those are your noodles in Koosh
in the run
my son my son was learning like Brian's
skin yeah my son was three or something
he just turned three and he's at the
playground he's playing with his kid and
he pushed a kid and a woman goes he's
got keep your boy away from me with his
mean little eyes he has mean eyes she's
not know I've seen anything like the the
hamsters with red eyes yeah he deserves
the white has red eyes he's a little
Damian from The Omen yeah and so he
struck her down with telepathy and oh my
god
yep bless his heart he gave her gangrene
he's doing better though on all her
limbs so they had do you double it was
so mean that she was so mean to him and
I was my wife started to cry and then I
I just like she started crying my wife
cried as her baby and I looked at her
and I look at her I think I said I
looked at her no way you are a lovely
lady I know he does have mean eyes and
you are loved that's all you said she
goes I don't need your sarcasm I go it's
not sarcasm you're lovely while you let
off these I don't know what to say you
know my son was right there that's nice
of you Brian you mean little eyes you
have a good heart I do when I fall in
her home and I slew her family you're
the goalie all these years yeah you're
the golden shower killer oh wait a
minute hey if they got DNA in 30 years
what are they gonna have besides DNA are
they gonna go tap into your brain and
get a map of your brain dude you know
what they're gonna have which is
horrifying is your old headshots Nick
it's not that bird it's not that much of
a bird hmm it's not it's not that much
of a bird stop covering them oh my god
it's not that big of a bird it's not
that bad
oh that's so obnoxious oh all right
those all right who got me a little bit
you didn't get me a lot ah you are gonna
have you're gonna have to go the
hospital no I'm not I can't recover from
that I guess I can you saw Brian's old
head shots
what a salty little boy yes
wife ma'am you're being perverse I was
great many of those overall shorts
nothing else I don't remember that
little lollipop lollipop lollipop yeah
she just can't help us get me a price
misty next a teenager in Sarasota
Florida he did it you know those
promposals will you do something
extravagant to ask someone out on a for
the problem yeah he did it to his
girlfriend he tried to make a joke out
of it but the joke was pretty bad oh my
gosh what is wrong you said if I was
black I'd be picking cotton but I'm
white so I'm picking you gotta see it's
in Florida what doesn't matter where
it's at but it does
you got a read you're gonna know it does
Florida once again shocking another one
up there's a lot of [ __ ] that goes on
Florida so Bray and gay guys are getting
eaten by Gators [ __ ] that Gator kids
like what all right
yeah my last tour I had to go on social
media and I was like hey everybody like
chill out because my florida show I was
in Orlando and it was at a performance
art Center where they had like The Lion
King and like all these like wicked all
these musicals then they had my show
this is all these like tornadoes coming
in all these crazy people and you know I
love my fans in Orlando you're amazing
but uh they're people were vomiting in
the seats one guy passed out in the
bathroom vomited all over the place then
there was a brawl in the balcony with
two chicks we had to stop the show it
was just yeah there are two there
my experience in Florida it's funny
today the only times I've had major
fights break out and been threatened has
been in Florida I had a great time in
Florida I love it Florida is amazing
you'll be intent through the trunk this
crowd Calgary yeah what Canada some
exported out and they still made sure
yeah some of the best crowds in the
world Canada well we're that jerks
nobody will steal unless you know that
am i right
no you burned them though
you got it back I got it back you know
it's not gonna get something back Elton
John he'll never get that back we'll be
right back for more Bibles this pissed
me watch and pray Oh get the [ __ ] are
they not let them go to prom and it also
got a problem anymore
who's this date black or no no all right
oh my god if that chick went with them
after that sign that's a toughy be tough
terrible joke yeah I'm really a joke is
a clumsy joke yeah but you're also it's
a no no no it's not a joke get some more
mean-spirited yeah it's just racism but
you haven't if you don't know what
you're crowd though you know you grab
what happens if it's girls like super
racist and she's the only time it's
acceptable to bang a racist as if she's
superhot everyone knows that that's
science and yeah and then you put up
with whatever I said I said these three
black days I was talking to who are
actors who'll go
remain nameless and we were hanging out
and looking at girls and he goes he's
gonna walk by his gut damn it I go
that's ridiculous and then I go no hear
me out
she was a racist and she went to Klan
rallies you'd hit it a couple times and
they all go yeah I'll take one for the
team there what else get Jen a quick
update on that killer
so it says DeAngelo which is the
killer's name was arrested after police
match discarded DNA evidence from his
Sacramento area home with genetic
evidence from the crimes was genetic so
off of their bodies innocent we have to
get let's do one more let's do one more
than yell at Nick Kroll I think that's
pretty much it actually and I said Nick
Kroll not Nick Kroll right yeah
you didn't say rickroll no Brian
rickroll Brian don't know what that is
Brian you should take your friends to it
so here's know here's the here's the
story about the girl who died in the
plane crash
yeah I'm gonna end with this so she
worked for a French events planner
she had serious issues about flying
especially since she was doing the JFK
Paris they don't kidding she was seeing
a therapist about it specifically we
already know that very cute doesn't
matter
right now there's and so this is from a
she called her brother and told me she
was having anxiety issues about the
flight since she had a nightmare about
it of course a lot of decision - yeah
I'm trying to be respectful I'm sorry
I'm hope I'm not as you know that plane
blew up and half the plan was still
flying through the air with passengers
strapped in it since it was the start of
the flight they were looking at the
stars and then watching as there was no
front the plan just impending don't do
what is happening I know right in the
Atlantic her what and the worst
nightmare of being realized I thought
that was that's the story oh this might
roll it's like no there's no new
information well yeah okay but isn't
that [ __ ] up that the plane breaks in
half and we've already gone over it very
quickly I'm sorry but I hope you break
it now all right
I feel bad I'm sure people wouldn't be
breaking the half from laughter at your
new tour yes they are
yeah Nick sorts and dotnet for tickets
yep it's gonna be a block it's gonna
come and open for me and Brendan's going
to open for me
July 20th Italia Hall Nick's gonna do
five minutes and then do a smooth hour
you're gonna do a tight hour and then
I'm gonna do my hour and we're gonna
shoot that Thalia I'll get your tickets
now a minutes is a lot that's a time and
then Nick I'm in your hood next week I'm
at a house of comedy Minnesota Mall of
America are you really when next week
next week May fifth and six
oh nice go see Brennan all right might
be May fourth fifth and six
either way I'm their support of
Minnesota for me yeah I don't support
Brian I'm so I'm in Denver this weekend
then I'm in Costa Casino May 5th and
Nick is also opening for me there what
oh wow these friend rumors bro and I'm
in West Nyack the falling weekend I'm in
every city ever ever built thanks coming
on Nick one down here for a while sir I
love you guys we did it great love it's
three words booking a movie hey Fredo
this is the vine kid brow